some good news out of washington mitch
mcconnell the senate republicans and the
last two moderate democrats on earth
blocked the democrats attempted federal
takeover of elections
the biggest power grab attempt that i
have ever seen
in my lifetime in this country would
have likely given democrats
permanent majorities later today
the senate will vote on whether to
advance democrats transparently partisan
plan to tilt every election in america
permanently
in their favor by now the rotten
inner workings of this power grab have
been thoroughly exposed
to the light it's a recipe for
undermining confidence in our elections
we're remaking our entire system of
government to suit the preferences of
one far end
of the political spectrum and if they
could
many democrats would pass it with the
slimmest possible
majority even after its companion faced
bipartisan opposition
over in the house what a craven
political
calculation what a way to show your
disdain
for the american people's choices the
senate is no obstacle to voting laws
done the right way the senate is only an
obstacle when the policy
is flawed and the process
is rotten today the senate is going to
fulfill our founding purpose
stop the partisan power grab and reject
s-1 and with that mr cocaine mitch
shut down the debate and the law died at
least for now
democrats are complaining in particular
that republicans
avoided debate on the bill but sometimes
it's good to avoid debate as my friend
steven crowder showed yesterday
when some lib ambushed him as the u.s
olympic team is learning right now
now that one of its athletes is
promising to burn the american flag
and now that critical race theory has
infected even the u.s military
maybe we have entertained a little too
much debate
from bad faith radicals i'm michael
knowles this michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from fern diaz 7 who
says
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for or against abortion
then you ain't catholic that is uh very
true that is very true an important line
that joe biden could learn from himself
but somehow the democrats just don't
want to acknowledge it
cocaine mitch shut it down what would
this bill have done had democrats gotten
this through
s-1 and h.r 1 colloquially known as the
corrupt politicians act
democrats called it the for the people
act but we all know what it really is
the bill would have federalized
congressional elections
would have declared that standard state
and local election systems
you know ways to keep the voter rolls
purged of eligible voters limiting
voting by mail requiring voter id all
that sort of stuff
that would be uh gone couldn't couldn't
really do that
required all challenges to the law to be
filed in federal courts in washington dc
so you wouldn't be able to get to fight
it really at the state level
it would have established online and
automatic voter registration
for the millions and millions of illegal
aliens they knew they knew
that illegal aliens would have been
registered to vote they denied
that fact but then the next provision of
the of the law
would have protected illegal aliens from
prosecution if they did vote
so they wouldn't have included that
provision had they actually believed
that the law would not be registering
illegal aliens to vote would have
established same-day voter registration
would have registered minors to vote
that's what we need we need to lower the
voting age in this country right
would have mandated early voting which
is a terrible idea
and it would have established nationwide
vote by mail without
voter id also would have allowed ballots
to be counted 10 days after the election
day
remember what happened in 20 2020 you
remember
that things were looking like they were
going one way in the election then
everyone just kind of stopped counting
everyone took a little pause and then
all of a sudden
the ballot count started to go the other
way it's pretty strange probably
shouldn't be able to do that sort of
thing so this is this is good stuff we
so rarely
report on good stuff coming out of
washington especially out of the
republican establishment
but stopping this power grab actually
was a very important thing
and i mention it not just for the good
news about the policy
but i mention it because of what it
tells us about debate
the democrats who as far as i can tell
are not
all that in favor of free speech these
days they're not very in favor of
hearing out the other side and dealing
with serious arguments and going back
and forth
they're complaining that we did not have
a debate
over s1 sometimes it's good
not to have debate when your opponents
are not
playing fair when your opponents are not
playing in good faith
then very often it's wise to avoid
debate my friend steven crowder
learned this yesterday i i don't know
either of the non-stephen crowder in
involved in this incident
there was stephen crowder and then some
lib that he was going to debate and then
some other lib
jumped in and he was secretly going to
debate him instead or something
it was all this kind of inner youtube
drama that i really don't know anything
about
but the it actually highlights the very
same principle that we're talking here
that was going on in washington dc so
just to give you some context
crowder agrees to debate this one guy he
actually jokes he says i bet this guy
doesn't want to debate me and then at
the very last minute it was a bait and
switch and they swapped him out for some
some other lib take a listen hi stephen
hey ethan how you doing brother
hey i just want to say on a serious note
that i'm glad you're um
your wife is okay i heard you had a
little bit of a yeah
with your wife well she's uh she's
pregnant with twins so yeah
it's like uh well by the way
congratulations too i know you guys are
thank you
in the same process all right man well i
appre i appreciate you coming on and
doing this and you know doing this
uh a lot of people don't so just talking
avoiding kind of the social media piston
contest drama all right okay i'm really
glad to have
my next guest on the show and i've
always said this i always respect people
who um
enter the enter into the arena uh ethan
thanks man for making the time you're
very welcome and i just want to say i
know you called me you said that i would
be a layup
i think i used something like that yeah
i think you're right because i don't
think i'm a very good debater
i think you know that so uh i didn't
want to make it too easy for you
oh okay so uh i've prepared
okay stephen do you know that um the
spartans
are that they are like uh
practice man love with children oh jeez
okay so this is what's gonna happen i
told what did i tell you he was going to
do anything he could to avoid
oh oh there he is oh no sam cedar what
up well what a [ __ ] nightmare
i had no idea this was going to happen i
have a gentleman this is a great
opportunity i don't started to be
based with people on a lie and how about
you sabotaging how about you guys even
show yourself steven show yourself
okay i think we can pause the debate
there i think we've gotten all of the
important content that we can get
out of this crowder agrees to debate
this one guy that i've never heard of
but then at the last second some other
guy that i'm not familiar with
who actually one of the reasons this was
called to my attention is because people
were saying that this other guy sam
sater looks like the kroger store
version of me
he's got i don't know he's got similar
skin and kind of glasses or whatever
so uh then he jumps in at the last
minute and then they they just start
insulting one another
and crowder says okay i'm not doing this
this is this is not what i signed up for
crowder was right not to
debate these guys frankly the only
mistake that crowder made
was agreeing to debate this jerk in the
first place these guys
i again i i don't want to speak out of
turn because i really don't know who
these people are
other than stephen crowder but they
don't seem like very serious people
it doesn't seem like anything productive
would come out of just talking to either
of these guys
so don't do it here's a very important
political lesson for you
never wrestle a pig you will both get
dirty but the pig will like it
this is what i'm fine i love debating
people
on the left i like debating people on
the right i especially
love debating squishes in the center
because i want to pry them over to my
side
but you have to have a purpose to the
debate
okay we i think on the right have have
really gotten high on this
idea of the free marketplace of ideas
and you challenge
bad ideas with good ideas yes
that's all well and good but you need to
make sure you're actually engaging with
ideas you need to make sure that that
you and the other the debate opponent
agree on the purpose of the debate
if the purpose of the debate is to hash
out some issue to prove your side or to
persuade one another
that's all well and good if the purpose
of the debate is to just score some
cheap point
and try to humiliate somebody or try to
insult or make jokes about somebody
without any real substance there there's
no point to that there's
there is nothing dignified or or
wonderful about engaging in the free
marketplace of ideas to
to get in the mud with pigs i don't i
don't know why anybody
would do that sort of thing you you need
to at least
agree on the basic premises before you
get into it we're actually seeing this
play out not just
on the internet but also on the us
olympic team
you know these people who are on the
olympic team they they can do for
themselves
generally right these are very talented
people if you want to be able to do for
yourself by the way i would recommend
checking out
rockauto.com we're all very very busy
these days
okay and so when you need a part for
your car or truck when you need
something fixed up on there what are you
going to do are you going to go to the
brick and mortar auto parts store you're
going to drive you're going to get there
you're going to walk in you're going to
get peppered with a thousand questions
many of which you won't know the answer
to
then the guy who asks you the questions
is going to go in the back and
what's going to happen that's probably
an empty room they're not going to have
the part
they're going to go online probably to
rockauto.com they're going to order the
part they're going to charge you twice
as much
so then you get to pay extra money to
have wasted hours of your life don't do
that
don't do that go to rockauto.com they've
always got the lowest price as possible
they don't change their prices based on
all these sorts of gimmicks you know but
order it tuesday morning or wednesday
afternoon no family business
same price for pros and
do-it-yourselfers the website is so
simple to navigate even i can do it head
on over to rockauto.com
right now to check out every part
available for your car or truck
then write knowles k-w-l-e-s and their
how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you a u.s
olympian
a transgender athlete who was chosen as
an alternate to represent the u.s
at the summer olympics is a bmx
freestyle rider apparently there's a
bicycle sport in the olympics
and uh his name is chelsea wolf i guess
he's a he's a guy who now pretends to be
a woman
and he says that quote
my goal is to win the olympics so i can
burn
a u.s flag on the podium there are many
problems with this fella joining the u.s
olympic team
not the least of which is he would be
competing as a woman but he's not a
woman he's a man
but actually even more important than
that this guy
wants to represent the united states at
the olympics
but he hates the united states he wants
to represent the united states
so that he can humiliate the united
states so he can
burn the symbol of the whole country
he should not be permitted he should not
be permitted on the team because he's a
dude
but there's there are many reasons he
should not be here but he should not be
permitted on the team
more importantly even because
he's not on the team he's not on the
bigger team which is
the american team you should this is a
good example
of cancel culture he he posted this this
comment to facebook when he said he
wants to burn the american flag on the
podium
we should cancel him for that that's
good that's a good use of cancel culture
i i always go back to that chesterton
line
there's a thought that stops thought and
that's the only thought that ought to be
stopped
there is an american olympian that that
stops the american olympians
that undermines our presence there that
sort of thing
ought to be stopped the the olympic
podium is not a free marketplace of
ideas
when you're out there representing the
same thing could be said of
all of our sports this is one of one of
the aspects that was so
offensive about the colin kaepernick
thing games
sports always have a patriotic quality
when you abuse
those sorts of things to attack your own
country
that is ugly it's counterproductive and
you shouldn't be permitted to do it
kaepernick shouldn't have been permitted
to do it on the football field and
especially this
fella should not be permitted to do it
at the olympics
but there are different flags now that
people believe
represent them that this guy on the
olympic alternate
team does not believe that the american
flag represents him
i think that might be true of a great
many liberals
i don't think they a lot of them will
kneel not in veneration but in protest
of the american flag
a lot of them seem to prefer the rainbow
flag or the blm flag there's a new flag
which is it's like the rainbow flag on
steroids it's like if you took the
rainbow flag and mashed it up
with the blm flag and also and probably
the hammer and sickle too
it's called the progress pride flag
and the progress flag it's like the
rainbow flag with like some weird other
rainbow angles coming in and there's
like a transgender thing and there's
like a black thing and
it's very very confusing the state
department
is now going to fly that flag i'm not
joking
the secretary of state anthony blinken
made the announcement at an atlantic
council event to talk about the liberal
establishment
this is one of these shadowy
organizations that just sort of pushes
the broad internationalist liberal
establishment consensus
blinken says i think this is going to be
a significant couple of days
and we will see the progress flag flying
at the state department
it's a quote symbol that encompasses the
diversity and intersectionality
of lgbtqi persons
and communities around the world and uh
and has been been approved to fly this
month all over the place
very distressing very sad for our
country
but this is not surprising i was not
surprised when i saw this at all
the american flag is the symbol of the
american country
the pride flag is the symbol of the
liberal empire
right the american flag represents a
specific country with borders in a
specific place
the pride flag makes universal claims
about every country on earth
makes universal claims about human
nature who we are
our sexual desires what people should be
permitted to do in countries around the
world
so it is no surprise to me that the
state department which has always been
liberal and is basically the
institutional defender
of the american liberal empire would
gravitate toward
that flag that is the flag that more
accurately represents what that
institution wants to do
and what many liberals who support that
institution want to do
it's very sad but but when trump came
out came out
when trump came out and said that the
battle in the election would be one
between nationalism
and globalism he might as well have said
it's a battle between these two flags
do we want the american way of life the
traditional american understanding of
our country and who we are
or do we want this radical new
universalist thing that's been bubbling
up at least since woodrow wilson
and has been gaining steam more and more
and more
that's that's a real battle and radicals
have
infiltrated our institutions up to and
including the state department
to push us toward that latter direction
which you can read a lot about in my
new book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now for
order
it's hard to get used to saying that i
was saying my upcoming pre-order but no
it's out now it was released yesterday
thank you to everybody who who ordered
it
this book is doing very well on the
sales charts
i really want to stick a finger in the
eye of the new york times and make them
put me on the list
but really i appreciate everyone who's
people have written in
and said you know they've read several
chapters already so that's very kind i
appreciate that
the first time i write a book with words
i'm glad to know people people are
reading them because it we are seeing
this play out right now it's in all of
the institutions
no institution is safe from this the one
institution
that we used to believe in this country
was safe from this kind of woke
craziness
obviously it's not hollywood it's not
the media it's not the bureaucracy it's
not
big tech we used to think the military
was safe
but it no longer is the chief of naval
operations
the cno was just asked by senator tom
cotton a military veteran
himself whether
he would disavow the statement that is
in in part of the navy's reading list
now that capitalism
is racist that the navy has this reading
list that they put out and they're
recommending
that that service and that sailors read
these insane leftist critical race
theory
books and cotton said hold on cnn do you
really believe that this is the sort of
thing
that's going to get our our servicemen
in fighting form
and the cno refuses to disavow
you're saying it's the senior leader of
the navy that you want 18 year old
sailors and 22 year old ensigns
to read a book that asserts that
capitalism is essentially
racist do you agree that capitalism is
essentially racist
sir i'm with all due respect i'm not
going to engage without understanding
the context of
of statements like that and talking to
sailors over the past year it's
clearly obvious to me and others that
the murder of george floyd and the
events
surrounding that the discussions in this
country about racism which go back
for years and years and years are still
a painful part
uh part of our culture and that talking
about them
understanding them is the best approach
um
and that and offering books like candies
for people to read
and they don't have to agree with every
assertion that candy makes
i i don't uh i don't accept every
assertion that candy makes
and i wouldn't think that uh that all
sailors would as well
but they need to be exposed to it so
that they're making
facts based we need critical thinkers
in the navy somebody put a pink hat on
his head
somebody paint his fingernails rainbow
what this is so pathetic
maybe all those colors that he's wearing
on his on his chest you know i
i thought that had military significance
it might be the progress pride flag this
is so pathetic
to see this coming out of our u.s
military for goodness sakes
defending crt defining defending
radical racialist theories good grief
man how pathetic
we got to clear some house with the top
brass over there at the pentagon
the let's just take his argument for
what it is
it's completely preposterous he's saying
and you hear this a lot he's making the
same argument that everyone makes with
the free marketplace
of ideas well we might not agree with
ibram kendy's book
but our sailors and our ensigns they
need to be exposed to all of these ideas
and then he starts bringing up george
floyd which is an entire
other matter but it shows that this guy
is obviously accepting radical leftist
premises
but it's just bs this guy doesn't
believe this this guy doesn't believe
that the ensigns and the sailors need to
be
opened up to every single idea is the
guy going to put mind conf on the
reading list
i don't think so is the guy going to put
is the guy going to put speechless on
the reading list
for that matter probably according to
this insane
chief of naval operations probably those
are equally evil terrible bigoted books
no of course not the reading list is
only so long the sailors are only
going to be exposed to so many ideas the
military literally brainwashes you
that is one of the points of military
training it is not
a student cafe where we can just debate
all sorts of ideas
and what this cno has decided is that
radical
leftist ideology critical race theory
ibram candy all that extrapolate
trash is worth being put into our
sailors minds it's worth
poisoning our sailors minds it's just
outrageous
this stuff needs to be banned we should
not be
permitting this sort of thing to infect
our military
they should be reading good books like
speechless
thank you so much to everyone who's brew
it's now available everywhere at your
local bookstore
at amazon barnes noble you may still be
able to get a copy of premiere
collectibles i'm actually not sure about
that
that may have ended with the pre-order i
know they sold out there they might be
getting some more in so anyway you can
check that out if you want to get an
autographed first edition thank you to
everyone who has bought it
sincerely i i really really appreciate
it i hope you enjoy the book let me know
what you think about it it's no secret
that the left has gone too far left that
is why
it is time for some voices of reason
such as the people in this
studio to discuss how we can save
america from its radical fate join me
jeremy boring ben shapiro and andrew
clavin
for another cigar packed session of
backstage streams tomorrow
june 24th at 7 pm eastern 6 pm central
at dailywire.com and on our youtube
channel
daily wire it's easy to remember because
it's just the name of the company head
on over there we'll be right back with a
lot more
the chief of naval operations says that
that sailors need to read
trash like ibram kendy's stupid book
because we need critical thinkers
in the military i think what he really
means is we need critical theorists in
the military
i think he means that we need these
radical
ideologues and do you know how we're
hovering right above the target
to use a military analogy do you know
how i know that the right
is right to go after critical race
theory and its
associated academic movements because
the left is retreating they're running
away you'll notice
that their their new argument is
critical race theory doesn't exist
they'll say what is critical race theory
it's a retreat to nominalism as my
friend matt peterson at claremont
pointed out
nominalism this idea that you know the
only the only general category is
they're just names they're just they
don't really refer to any any real
things
critical race theory what do you mean by
that you know come
on no i mean a body of i think i have a
book right here here it is
i mean this this body of work
called critical race theory by writers
such as kimberly crenshaw neil gontanda
gary peller kendall thomas and a number
of other people
who have developed this academic
movement out of critical theory more
broadly that
is attempting to subvert our entire
national self-understanding our personal
self-understanding for that matter
that's that's a problem we should not
be doing that the left will now say
there's no such thing as critical race
theory that's out of one side of their
mouth and then out of the other side of
their mouth they'll say
and also critical race theory is great
they're doing this with juneteenth
i knew it by the way i hate you know i
hate to say i told you so they push for
juneteenth
the the squishes just roll over on
juneteenth and then what happens they
say well
we have the juneteenth holiday but uh
you know juneteenth doesn't mean
anything because you're not even allowed
to teach people about their race
you're not even the republicans don't
even want us to teach people about
slavery
because they're kicking critical race
theory out of the classroom
you're telling me you're telling me
without critical race theory people
would not be taught that slavery exists
i think they would pretty sure we've
taught that before
critical race theory something quite
different and quite
radical this is real
this is infecting not just the
universities
not just the high schools but corporate
boardrooms even the us military
and it's leading to some really kooky
suggestions the washington post
just came out and said that in order to
grapple
with our with racism and in order to
cast a truly critical lens white people
need to form and engage in white
accountability groups racism
racialization white body supremacy
is not episodic it's structural remember
that there were um thousands of george
floyd before the one that you saw
your bodily response to this this horror
right is not the same thing as
you dealing with the structural aspects
of this
george floyd's death became a deeply
personal and racial tragedy for many
americans for the first time white
people were becoming
aware of their whiteness and the
systemic ways that white supremacy
affects
all of us white people in particular get
aroused to get upset say this is unjust
this isn't right this shouldn't happen
there's like an awakening that happens
and so part of their
racial identity development is seeing
that awakening
white accountability groups are really
helpful in terms of having a place to
process
having a group of people whose
responsibility
it is to call me on things or to
challenge me
okay there are two things going on here
obviously these women are
absolutely daft but the points they're
raising speak to true things the first
one
probably the most interesting aspect is
that these radical leftists are
calling for a white racial consciousness
you know white people do not have much
racial consciousness
the pew research center showed this just
a few years ago
they measured racial consciousness they
asked people
is your race somewhat or very important
to your identity
for every racial group other than white
people
more than 50 percent of the respondents
said yes race is somewhat or very
important to my identity
this is true among asians it was true
among hispanics it was especially true
among black people
black people's racial consciousness is
higher than 70
for white people it's 15
it's very very low contrary to what
you've heard about white supremacy and
all the other nonsense
white people do not have a racial
consciousness
there have been white identitarians
there have been
people who have called for a white
racial politics
who have said whites need to get their
racial consciousness up
and some people who say that today for
the purpose
of creating racial solidarity in the way
that other racial groups do it
but these leftist radicals do not
advocate racial consciousness among
whites
for the purpose of giving them
solidarity obviously it's for the
purpose
of instilling shame in them so it's this
unique
case and this has been going on for many
decades now especially since the 1970s
there's been a real effort on the left
to cultivate racial consciousness
among hispanics among asians um these
are
by the way two racial categories that
were basically invented in the 1970s
before that you would talk about
mexicans or guatemalans or
chinese or japanese but you wouldn't
talk about asian that's so many people
hispanic well it's like a quarter of the
earth i don't know so many people
but it was felt on the left
that in order to mirror the political
achievements
of the black civil rights movement they
would have to create these groups
so for all the other racial groups
the left cultivates racial consciousness
to instill
racial pride for white people
the left cultivates racial consciousness
to instill
racial shame it is so perverse
it is so weird now i think every group
could probably learn more from the shame
part of it than the pride part of it
pride goeth before destruction and a
haughty spirit before a fall
and shame gives us a sense
of sin so i think what's going on here
when we talk about a racial what do they
call the white accountability group
what these people are really trying to
get at is
confession that's just their whiteness
for them
is just a synonym for sin and
accountability groups
is a synonym for confession like you go
into a confessional and confess your
sins to a priest
or some people confess their sins to one
another in a small group
that's what's going on except the sin
here is just
being white that's that's the stand-in
and so
under this perverse theory no one has
anything to feel sorry for
except for white people because no one
has free will no one has moral agency
other than white people that according
to this idea very bizarre you can see
how
serious ideas can just be so perverted
to
to make no sense whatsoever according
according to these guys and specifically
according to
the mayor of washington dc
but but mayors across the country you
see this with lori lightfoot in chicago
and other race hustlers according to
these people
white supremacy is
pervasive and invisible and we need
accountability for it
now black lives matter violence
is very visible quite pervasive we can
see it happening before our eyes
and we all need to deny it if you asked
any lib on the street
today what's a bigger problem in america
white supremacy
or black lives matter terrorism
i bet especially if people were in
public and they couldn't tell you what
they
believe in their heart of hearts they
just had to say the line that is
socially accepted they would say white
supremacy it's a horrible white
supremacy is the greatest
problem in america where is it
show me the white supremacy show me on
the map
where the white supremacy is because i
can show you where the blm terrorism is
it's in minneapolis it's in washington
dc it's in los angeles it's in new york
it's in chicago
it's all over the place it's in
nashville for goodness sakes
not anymore but during the heat of the
2020 riots there was violence they set a
courthouse on fire
so i can show you that but you can't
show me the white supremacy
senator ron johnson republican just
grilled the mayor of dc
muriel bowser about this issue of blm
terrorism do you have a property damage
estimate
from the summer riots uh i'm i'm glad to
hear
you say that you are opposed to riotous
behavior whether it happened
on 16th street or here matt madame could
you could you could you answer the
question do you have an
estimate of the property damage during
the summer riots i know that we had
one night of um rioting
in the district one night one night of
rioting
for during blm in washington dc is that
true
i was personally in washington dc for
more than one night
of leftist blm violence okay
we all know that that is bs there's
video of this sort of thing
and she just lied ron johnson asks a
perfectly fair question
what was the cost of the blm riots um
yeah i'm glad that you're interested and
i don't but i don't
answer the question mayor bowser what
was the cause well we had one night
one night just total gaslighting
total gaslight that's this is not
someone engaging in the free marketplace
of ideas this is not
not someone having a real deliberative
exercise here this is
unreasonable logic-free
grunting interest politics
a lot of violence in our streets there
was a lot of violence
on juneteenth our most sacred national
feast day
juneteenth you know as of uh but eight
minutes ago no juneteenth is
the national independence day that's
actually the name of the act
the juneteenth national independence day
act
so the left contrives this holiday out
of some local
tradition in galveston they invent this
whole new national holiday
and there was violence at juneteenth
celebrations
juneteenth partiers shot up a
celebration in oakland
but that wasn't even the craziest part
you had about 5 000 people
gathered at lake merrit in oakland
california to celebrate
juneteenth and uh seven people get shot
at this celebration gosh sure got rowdy
then an ambulance shows up
and the feast goers started
twerking on the ambulance
you can say when they're trying to like
wheel people into this ambulance
and there's a there's a young woman of
multiple young women
yeah there we go twerking on men on the
ambulance everyone filming it
probably making it pretty tough to put
the injured people into the ambulance
filming laughing then some guy just
jumps up climbs on top of the ambulance
yeah he's throwing a football that looks
fun
football they're trying to like be nice
maybe you know when i see an ambulance
behind me in traffic i usually pull to
the shoulder of the road
because i want to make sure i don't want
to impede the ambulance's journey
but these guys didn't didn't want the
ambulance to impede their ability to
grind on one another
and and dance on a car and throw
a football i mention this
not only because i think the juneteenth
national holiday is
a farce and a very bad idea but also
because
i never want to hear about police
brutality again
okay i never want to hear about
over-incarceration
and all these and you know the white
supremacist
law enforcement
you saw this the other day actually
there were people twerking on a cop car
in where was it chicago or new york and
the car kept driving they're like get
off the car
stop it but they're not really doing
anything about it
you you have a very dangerous situation
where people are getting
shot where people need to be taken back
to the hospital where you got to get out
of the way of the ambulance
then you've got a bunch of absolute
degenerates dancing and jumping and
climbing on a car nothing happens no
consequences whatsoever
you've got crime spiking right now in
cities around the country notably
chicago
where shootings and murders are up 50
and what happens
no one does they all complain about
police brutality on the left
they all complain about the
over-incarceration
we have a severe under-incarceration
problem in this country
but just by definition if crime is
spiking if criminals are running free on
the street
then we are under incarcerating people
we need criminal justice reform
to put more criminals in prison it's not
going to happen though
blm rioters are getting completely off
the hook i mean
we talked about it either yesterday or
the previous episode on this show
in the bronx the majority of blm
terrorists are just they're just having
the cases dismissed
the looters the rioters just doesn't
matter now if you go and dance on nancy
pelosi's desk
in a horn helmet then you're gonna get
the book thrown at you you're probably
gonna go to gitmo
but if you shoot up parties if you dance
on ambulances and cop cars
if you riot in city after city after
city and you loot stores
totally fine is that does that seem fair
to you
does that seem like the sort of
civilized society where everyone's
playing by the rules and we can engage
in the free marketplace of ideas i'm not
so sure about that
gensake the white house press secretary
tells us that there is one real threat
in this country
that we need to focus on not the thugs
shooting people in chicago
not the blm and antifa terrorists that
have burned down the country for a year
not the looters and the rioters and the
killers and no
we need to worry about trump
there is a reporter again i don't know
what outlet he's from
a leftist reporter who pointed out that
president trump is about to start
holding rallies again
and he wants to know
if the white house is concerned about
the inevitable violence
is the administration concerned that
actual uh violent extremists and people
espousing secessionist rhetoric are
finding a home
in republican primaries and could
actually be elected to office and then i
have that second question
well i'm not going to label people
domestic violent extremists officially
from here
i think we have certainly seen
problematic rhetorics
followers of q anon and conspiracy
theories who not just who don't just run
but are elected to office
so there's already a record of that
president biden's predecessor is going
to
return to his campaign-style rallies in
ohio
this coming weekend has anyone from the
administration reached out to governor
dewine
or anyone in ohio's government about the
possibility of
violence resulting from his return to
the trail
and is there any concern
him going back out there and continuing
to insist that the election is
fraudulent
uh and that he actually won could result
in
people being hurt or killed obviously we
take um
the rhetoric of uh the
the other the the former guy as we like
to say uh quite seriously
as everyone should but i don't have any
uh readouts or
or calls with governor devil wine um jen
could you just uh could you say that the
republicans are all evil
terrible anti-american people
and and you're afraid of the uh all the
violence
the left right now is promising to
to burn the american flag on the olympic
podium
the left right now is actively
encouraging political violence as it has
for
years and i'm not just talking about
kooks i'm talking about maxi well i am
talking about kooks but very prominent
kooks
maxine waters hillary clinton kamala
harris bailing rioters out of jail
calling for for riots in the case of
maxine waters calling for democrats to
be uncivil with republicans
instituting a new national independence
day and waving a new american flag
and this guy is
worried about the secessionist rhetoric
of
democrats the left spends a year
burning down the country and this guy is
worried about
the violent extremism of
republicans what
what on earth does this
they're how do you resp i i'm actually
speechless there's just the title of my
upcoming book it's my book that's out
right now actually
how do you respond to that when a man is
so tuned out of reality
democrats are committing virtually all
of the violence and you
say you're worried about the republican
violence the
the left actively calling for this sorts
of violence you say well the right this
is the really violent terrible party the
former guy
the former guy i can't wait for trump to
hold more rallies
they're going to call us terrorists if
we so much as litter at any of these
rallies
you can't let that bother you it's just
not true
they're not engaging in good faith this
is not a fair debate that's going on
right now
just we got to do our thing guys we got
to tune it out
we should not be wrestling with pigs
speaking of trump supporters
and firearms for that matter i owe an
apology to the mccloskeys
you remember the mccloskeys mark and
patricia mccloskey were the
should be brooks brothers models who
were standing outside their home when
blm terrorists busted in started
breaking their property sort of
threatening their lives with weapons
and the mccloskeys had guns and said get
off my lawn great
great people great americans well they
pled guilty to misdemeanor charge
just last week i think had to turn over
their guns
and i said oh what a pathetic surrender
oh my god you did nothing wrong you
defended your property you defended the
constitution
now you're giving up your guns your
second amendment right you're pleading
guilty to this thing
well mark mccloskey just posted a photo
where he said checking out my new ar and
he was at the gun shop
buying a new ar-15
so what's going on here
i suspect this is a case of the
mccloskeys being wise as serpents
and innocent as dubs meaning there was
some charge there
the cops were trying to get them on a
felony what was the felony i don't know
they got the lawyers to plead it down to
some misdemeanor or something
they had to turn over just one or two
guns but they're very wealthy people
obviously
and then they just went out and bought
more guns to survive another day to keep
on fighting
sometimes one needs a tactical retreat
the line between courage and
recklessness can be a little bit blurry
so if we're talking about s1 and hr1
over on capitol hill you don't always
need to engage in the debate sometimes
you just got to
kill the bill if you're talking about my
friend steven crowder
you don't always need to engage with
these jerks you don't always need to
jump in with the pigs
you can tactically retreat if you're the
mccloskeys
you don't always need to make every
battle a federal issue
you can take your light see where it is
and then
try to live to fight another day
you're seeing this kind of radicalism
bubbling up
everywhere and we really need to push
back against this sort of thing
you're seeing it in the movies there's a
new movie coming out
demonizing white women called karen
we'll
we'll have to talk about that perhaps
tomorrow there's much to say about that
there are new events leftist events
around the country that are charging
extra fees to white attendees
at their reparations fees to show up
they're the left is playing
to win the left is not playing to really
convince anybody or persuade anybody
this is just
clubby on the head type of interest
politics with
physical threats in many case in many
cases
the right has no obligation to to
engage in the very formal marquess of
queensberry
style rules of debate i don't think that
the the left is interested in that
and i think that we should take our wins
when we can get them
and i hope we can all have civilized
debate again someday but for right now
we need to take those political wins i'm
michael noel's this michael and all
shall see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show the washington post
concludes that higher numbers of black
traffic debts
are the result of you guessed it
infrastructure racism and
before the people act died in
ignominious death to the whales and
teeth gnashing of the media
that's today on the bench fair shall
give it a listen